My name is Sebastien Noel.
I'm one of the three founding directors of Troika together with Conny Freyer and Eva Rucki.
Troika is an art and design studio based in London.
I'm from France.
The two other are from Germany.
And this is "See Britain Through Troika's Eyes"
I was originally working in Italy...
...and very soon I felt the need to go and do a postgraduate in design.
And I guess I chose to come here in England...
...because you have the Royal College of Art...
...which was one of the best schools in Europe.
Already during college time we had worked together quite a lot.
So, I decided to set up a studio a year after leaving the college.
I think in general, clients in the UK are quite happy to take well comparably quite large risks...
...like commissioning people coming out of their degree.
For British Airways we created a five-meter-long sculpture,...
...two-meter-wide, one-meter-tall that is suspended in the first class interior in Terminal Five, Heathrow.
It is covered with 5,000 little mirrors like that, that can flip from one side to the other...
...so we can animate the whole skin of the sculpture.
This is what was used in old train stations and airports to display information...
...and go...
We're kind of re-exploring an older technology...
...and see what kind of identity it could have over a more conventional technique.